RESOURCES WILL COME TO ORDER.
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE A HAPPY
NEW YEAR WELCOME WELCOME BACK.
IN RESPONSE THE COMPANY EIGHTEEN
EMERGENCY AND TO PROTECT THE
PUBLIC LEGISLATORS AND EMPLOYEES
WE MUST LIMIT NONESSENTIAL
GATHERINGS RENDON HERE TO SOCIAL
DISTANCING FACE COVERING
GUIDELINES IN COMPLIANCE WITH
THOSE ORDERS THE SENATE HAS MADE
NECESSARY ADJUSTMENTS TO NORMAL
PRACTICES IN ORDER TO. ENSURE
THE PUBLIC CONTINUES TO HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS WELL THERE COMMITTEE
HEARINGS HERE IN THE CAPITAL AND
ASSET ALL MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE BE PRESENT NOW IN ROOM
FORTY TWO OR THREE- WE'VE GOT A
QUORUM THOUGH SO WE WILL BEGIN
THE HEARING. AND TO ALLOW THE
PUBLIC ACCESS WE'VE ADMITTED
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
HEARING ROOM TO THE EXTENT SUCH
DISTANCING REQUIREMENTS ALLOW
WILL BE USING A TELECONFERENCE
REVERSES FOR THOSE INDIVIDUALS
WHO WISH TO TESTIFY TODAY.
REMOTELY FOR ALL INDIVIDUALLY
FOR ALL INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PUBLICLY COMMENT THE PARTICIPANT
TOLL FREE NUMBER AND ACCESS CODE
IS POSTED ON OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE WILL ALSO BE DISPLAYED
ON THE SCREEN AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS. EIGHT
FOUR FOUR TWO NINE ONE SIX THREE
SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS CODE IS
THREE FIVE THREE ONE TWO EIGHT
THREE FOR DETAILED INSTRUCTIONS
ON HOW THE TELECONFERENCE ISTOM
WORKS PLEASE REFER TO THE SENATE
PANDORA COMMITTEE WEBSITE. WE
MOVED PUBLIC COMMENT YOU'LL BE
PROMPTED BY A MODERATOR TO DIAL
ONE AND ZERO FOR SUPPORT IN
OPPOSITION PRESS THIS ONLY ONE
TIME AND WAIT PATIENTLY FOR AN
OPERATOR TO ASSIGN YOU A LINE
NUMBER THIS CAN BE A SHORT WAIT.
ONCE YOU RECEIVE YOUR LINE
NUMBER YOU'LL WAIT IN THE QUEUE
FOR THE MODERATOR CALL YOUR LINE
NUMBER AT THAT TIME YOU WILL BE
A NEEDED AND YOU ARE NOW TO
ADDRESS THE COMMITTEE. PLEASE
NOTE THAT IN ORDER FOR US TO
HEAR YOU CLEARLY INTO AVOID
ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK YOU MUST MEET
THE DEVICE YOU'RE WATCHING THE
HEARING ON PRIOR TO GIVING THAT
TESTIMONY OVER THE PHONE. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE HEAR FROM YOU
AND WE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. I WILL MAINTAIN
DECORUM DURING A HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY AT ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTED MAY BE REMOVED FROM
THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE. OR
HAVE THEIR CONNECTIONS MUSIC. WE
HAVE- JUST ONE BILL HERE. ON THE
AGENDA- BUT BEFORE WE PRESENT ON
THAT BILL IT'S ESTABLISH A
QUORUM- MISTER CONSULTANT
WELCOME BACK AND WOULD YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. TURNS HERE
TURN HERE JONES. JONES HERE
ALLEN. EGGMAN EGGMAN HERE GROWTH
HERE GROW HERE HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HERE HUESO. HERE HUESO
HERE LOAN. LAVONE HERE LAYERED
HERE WHERE HERE. OKAY THANK YOU
SO MUCH- LET'S HEAR FROM OUR
FIRST AND ONLY AUTHOR OF A
SENATOR BATES WELCOME AND- YOU
HERE PERCENT SB SIX TO SEVEN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND A
GOOD MORNING ON MEMBERS I FIRST
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO THE
CHAIR AND YOUR STAFF ARE FOR THE
TIME AND CONSIDERATION THAT
THEY'VE GIVEN US BILLS WHEN OUT
THERE FLOATING AROUND SINCE THE
NINETEEN UNDER. A DIFFERENT
NUMBER BUT- CERTAINLY IT IS THE
SAME SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN
REQUIRES LOCAL SO COMMISSION AS
SET COASTAL ACT. TO
GRANT PERMITS TO CITIES COUNTIES
AND STATE AGENCIES AN OCEANFRONT
HOMEOWNERS OF FOR THE IN
SOLUTION INSTALLATION OF COASTAL
MITIGATION PROJECTS UNDER
CURRENT LAW ANY CONSTRUCTION
THAT ALTERS THE SHORELINE MUST
RECEIVE A PERMIT FROM THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL COMMISSION OR
THE PRESIDING LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
HOWEVER RESPONSE TIMES FOR
PERMIT APPLICATIONS OFTEN TAKE
MONTHS IN SOME CASES YEARS TO
APPROVE OR DISAPPROVE. THIS IS
UNACCEPTABLE AS THE DELAY AND
RESPONSE TIMES HAS LEFT OUR
COASTAL BLUFFS VIRTUALLY
UNCHECKED LEAVING BEACH GOERS
AND OCEANFRONT HOMEOWNERS
VULNERABLE TO THE DANGERS OF
COASTAL EROSION. IN RESPONSE TO
THESE THREATS SB SIX TWENTY
SEVEN WOULD REQUIRE THE COASTAL
COMMISSION TO APPROVE OR DENY AN
APPLICATION FOR A COASTAL
MITIGATION PROJECTS WITHIN
THIRTY DAYS OF IT SUBMISSION AND
I'D LIKE TO KNOW WHAT AT THIS
POINT TOP. TIER STERN BATCH THAT
IS CERTAINLY OPEN TO AMENDMENT
BECAUSE I THINK WE'VE ALL
WITNESSED IT MANY OF THE
AGENCIES THIRTY DAYS OF A VERY
SHORT TIME TO BE ABLE TO GO
THROUGH SOMETHING AS
COMPLICATED. AS A REQUEST FOR A
COASTAL FLOOD MITIGATION PROJECT
PERMIT OUT SO WITHOUT FIRMLY
OPEN FOR DISCUSSION AND I AM
VERY AWARE THAT THAT IS. A
LITTLE TOO AGGRESSIVE- TO PUT
UPON THE COASTAL COMMISSION AND
ITS STAFF. I DID INTRODUCED THIS
BILL BECAUSE OF WHAT HAPPENED IN
AUGUST OF TWENTY NINETEEN AT
GRAND VIEW BEATEN ANTHONY THIS
CALIFORNIA NOT IN MY DISTRICT
WHEN AN OCEAN FRONT BLUFF
SUDDENLY COLLAPSED AND KILLED
THREE MEMBERS OF THE DAVIS
FAMILY. WHO HAD GATHERED TO
CELEBRATE MRS ELIZABETH COX'S
VICTORY OVER BREAST CANCER
HOWEVER THIS WASN'T. THE FIRST
TIME THAT THIS HAS HAPPENED IN
OUR DISTRICT. THE SANTA AREA
TRIED FOLLOW SIMILAR PREVENTABLE
BY KALAU FATU. IN 959-952-0002
THOUSAND TWO. AND TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. IN OCTOBER OF TWENTY
EIGHTEEN A CONCRETE TO BEACH
WALKWAY NEAR THE BACK OF
CAPISTRANO BEACH IN ORANGE
COUNTY AND MY DISTRICT. COLLAPSE
AS A RESULT OF OCEAN DRIVE IN
EROSION. IN NOVEMBER OF TWENTY
NINETEEN A MAJOR BLUFF COLLAPSE
AND DEAL MARK BUT THE ENTIRE
COASTAL RAIL LINE IN JEOPARDY.
AND WILL NOW COST A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO FULLY REPAIR
AFTER THE FACT. AND JUST THIS
PAST OCTOBER METROLINK WAS ONCE
AGAIN IMPACTED ONE PART OF THE
RAIL LINE COLLAPSED IN THE CITY
OF SAN CLEMENTE. WE WILL
CONTINUE TO BE AT RISK IF WE DO
NOT ACT. I WOULD BE REMISS IF I
DID NOT ACKNOWLEDGE PRESIDNT
PRO TEM TONI ATKINS AND HER BILL
SENATE BILL ONE THAT THE
GOVERNOR JUST APPROVED. I
SUPPORTED THE BILL BECAUSE IT
BRINGS MUCH NEEDED RECOGNITION
OF THE LONG TERM EFFECTS OF SEA
LEVEL RISE IT PROVIDES VALUABLE
TOOLS TO ASSESS. PLAN AND
MITIGATE SEA LEVEL RISE. AND
ALSO PROVIDES RESOURCES TO DO
THE PROJECTS THAT COULD SAVE
CALIFORNIA. FROM THE IMPACT OF
SEA LEVEL RISE PROJECT OUR MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. AS MUCH
AS I VALUE SB ONE THIS BILL IS A
MUCH NEEDED COMPLIMENTARY
COMPLIMENTARY PIECE. TWO S. B.
ONE THAT WILL GIVE US A CHANCE
TO PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES WHO
ARE FACING IMMINENT THREATS.
WELL THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
PERCEIVED FLAWS IN MY BILL AS
CURRENTLY DRAFTED I AM COMMITTED
TO MAKING CHANGES NECESSARY. TO
AVOID UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES SO
WE DO STAND BY AND WATCH SO WE
DON'T STAND BY AND WATCH THE
BLUFFS AND BEACHES WASH AWAY
WHILE WE WAIT FOR THE PLAN FOR
THE S. B. IS PROMISING US. I
HAVE TWO WITNESSES WITH ME TODAY
THE FIRST IS DOCTOR PAT DAVIS A
RESIDENT OF ANTHONY THIS AND THE
SECOND IS TIM. BROWN A RESIDENT
OF SAN CLEMENTE. VERY GOOD THANK
YOU SENATOR BATES AND- WILL WILL
NOW MOVE ON TO OUR LEAD
WITNESSES- DOCTOR DAVIS- IT'LL
BE GOOD TO HEAR YOUR VOICE AND I
HOPE YOU'RE WITH US THIS MORNING
IF YOU'RE HERE- MODERATOR PLEASE
BRING DOCTOR DAVIS ON. YES I'M
HERE CAN YOU CAN YOU GUYS HEAR
ME YEAH WE CAN. OKAY- YOUR
SENATORS MR CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME IS DR
PAT DAVIS I'M SPEAKING TO YOU
TODAY TO SERVE IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. SIX TWENTY SEVEN SPONSORED BY
SENATOR BATES. ON AUGUST SECOND
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. WHAT
WAS SUPPOSED TO BE A DAY AT
GRANDVIEW BEACH CELEBRATING MY
SISTER-IN-LAW'S VICTORY OVER
BREAST CANCER. WE SHATTERED BY A
MASSIVE CLIFF COLLAPSE THAT
KILLED MY WIFE JULIE. MY
DAUGHTER ANNIE AND MY SISTER IN
LAW ELIZABETH. THEY'RE ALSO
TWELVE CHILDREN FAMILY MEMBERS
CLOSE BY COULD HAVE BEEN FATALLY
INJURED. THIS TRAGEDY COULD HAVE
BEEN PREVENTED THERE HAVE BEEN
EXTENSIVE STUDIES DONE BY THE
ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS AND MANY
OTHER AGENCIES THAT HAVE
PROPOSED NUMEROUS SOLUTIONS.
STABILIZE THESE DANGEROUS BLOCKS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA TO MAKE
ARE HEAVILY POPULATED BEACHES
SAFER. THE GATE THE CITY'S. THE
STATE AND COASTAL COMMISSION
HAVE NOT ENACTED ANY SOLUTIONS
TO MAKE OUR BEACHES SAFE SIR. IT
IS TIME THAT LEGISLATIVE ACTION
TAKES PLACE. POSTAL RELIGION AND
POOR MANAGEMENT OF OUR EXISTING
BLOCKS IS GOING TO CONTINUE TO
MAKE OUR BEACHES MORE AND MORE
DANGEROUS. THE ACCIDENT THAT
HAPPENED TO MY FAMILY WILL
HAPPEN AGAIN IF WE DON'T MAKE
CHANGES. SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN IS
A SOLUTION THAT WILL HELP SAVE
LIVES. THANK YOU VERY MUCHFOR
HEARING ME. THANK YOU DOCTOR
DAVIS- MISTER BROWN ARE YOU WITH
US. I AM WELCOME. THANK YOU MY
HEART GOES OUT TO DR DAVIS I'M
SO SORRY- THIS TERRIBLE TRAGEDY
I SPEAK Q. AS- MY NAME IS TIM
BROWN AND- GOOD AFTERNOON MR
MEMBERS I'M A FORMER MAYOR OF
THE CITY ST CLAIR WHERE I SERVED
EIGHT YEARS AS CITY COUNCILMAN
IN THIS COMMUNITY TODAY HOWEVER
SPEAK TO AS A RESIDENT OF SOUTH
WEST BANK MANY AN AFFRONT TO
DECIPHER SHORE COMMUNITY. OVER
THE LAST FORTY FIVE YEARS THIS
COMMUNITY HAS WATCHED ALMOST A
HUNDRED LINEAL FEET OF BEACH
SAND WORKS WITH AN GOING INTO
THIS LACK OF SAND THE MASSIVE
LANDSLIDES TRIGGERED UNDER THE
CLUBHOUSE AND FORGERIES ALL
EXTREMELY DANGEROUS FOUNDATIONS
CRACKED HOME SPLIT IN HALF TO
THE HOMES AT THE RED TAG TO
PREVENT GAS- GAS LEAKAGE AND
THAT SORT. OF LEAKAGES WHILE.
THE SITUATION BECAME MORE. HAS
SEPTEMBER WHEN THE RIVER TRACKS
LOW. DEBATE SLIDE BOOK LATERAL
ALMOST INCHES SHUT DOWN CRITICAL
REAL SERVICE FOR SAN. AND ORANGE
COUNTY. TO LINK WAS ONLY ABLE TO
ADDRESS A SLIP NOT MY- ELEVENTH
. FIVE HUNDRED TONS OF RIPRAP
ALONG THE BEACH. THE BILL SIX
SEVENTY TWO WILL PUT CREATE A
PROCESS TO EXPEDITE APPLICATIONS
FOR SHORELINE PROTECTION BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS BECAUSE
CONDITIONS. WOULD APPLY TO
SITUATIONSLIKE OURS WHERE THE
BLAST SLIPPAGE THREATENS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE PEOPLE'S
ARMS. AND ULTIMATELY ENDANGERS
THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITY IT
ALSO ALLOWS COAST COMMISSIONER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS REQUIRE
LANDOWNERS REPLENISHED BAND. YOU
KNOW TO THE PROJECT WHICH I
BELIEVE IS A GOOD THING SINCE
LOSSES AND CONTRIBUTES TO THE
ROCHA. THE PASSAGES BILL ONE BY
THE PRESIDENT PRO TEM. PROVIDES
A FRAMEWORK RESOURCE FOR LONG
TERM MITIGATION SEALEVEL RISE
AND I BELIEVE SENATOR BATES BILL
COMPLEMENT THAT EFFORT BY
STOPPING RUSSIAN AREAS. OR
THREATS TO THE PUBLIC SAFETY ARE
IMMINENT. ONE OF THE PRIMARY
GOALS OF THE COURSE MICHAEL'S
EXPAND PUBLIC ACCESS TO OUR
BEACHES WHAT'S HAPPENING NOW. TO
OUR BEACHES IN SOUTH ORANGE
COUNTY AND ACROSS CALIFORNIA
PRINCE REDUCE ACCESS THE
BEACHES. ANY ENJOYMENT OF THE
OPTIONS FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS
OF CALIFORNIANS. BOOKS FAMILY
WANT TO VISIT THE BEAUTIFUL
CALIFORNIA BEACH AND COASTLINE.
IF THAT DOESN'T MEAN SITTING ON
REPRAP AS THE OCEAN CRASHES INTO
THE ROCKS BELOW THAT. I
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY AND
ASK THAT YOU VOTE BY. ONE SENATE
BILL SIX TWENTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY MISTER BROWN-
WILL NOW- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO THE GENERAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT- DO WE HAVE ANY HERE IN
ROOM FORTY TWO OH THREE I DON'T
THINK WE DO- LET'S MOVE. WE
DON'T HAVE AN AUXILIARY ROOM
EITHER NO NO TWENTY FORTY TODAY
GOT IT- LET'S MOVE ON TO WIN
THIS IS WAITING TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE ARVEST. MODERATOR
WOULD YOU PLEASE PROPERTY
INDIVIDUALS WAITING. THANK YOU
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SHARE SUPPORT
FOR THIS MEASURE AND YOU MAY
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO ON YOUR
TELEPHONE. AN OPERATOR WILL
PROVIDE YOU YOUR LINE NUMBER.
AGAIN THAT COMMANDERS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO USING YOUR
TELEPHONE KEYPAD PLEASE. WE DO
HAVE A LINE IN Q. WE'LL ELEVEN. ONE ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MY NAME IS KELLY
GATHERED SOME OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF REALTORS WE
FIRMLY BELIEVE THAT SENATE BILL
SIX TWENTY SEVEN WILL HELP
COASTAL HOMEOWNERS AND
COMMUNITIES. AND DESPERATELY
NEEDED TIME TO DETERMINE THE
DISPOSITION OF HOMES
INFRASTRUCTURE AND OTHER
PROPERTIES IN LIGHT OF THE LEVEL
RIGHT. NOT THAT THE COMMITTEE
RECOGNIZES THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROVIDING THE INSURANCE WHICH
WILL PROTECT LIVES AND PROPERTY
RESPECTFULLY. REQUEST YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU. OKAY THANKS-
GOING FORWARD IS GOING TO SAY
NAME AND AFFILIATION HERE
ALTHOUGH I DON'T THINK WE HAVE-
MANY OTHERS IN IN TESTIMONY BUT
WHEN YOU DO PRESENT JUST YOUR
NAME AND WHETHER YOU'RE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND WHERE
YOU'RE FROM- PUTS MODERATOR
LET'S MOVE TO THE NEXT CALLER.
THANK YOU ONCE AGAIN IF YOU WISH
TO SHARE SUPPORT FOR THIS BILL.
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO. THANK
YOU THEY'RE KNOWN FOR THE LINES
INTO AT THIS TIME. OKAY THANK
YOU MR MODERATOR- NOW WE HAVE
HEARD FROM ALL SUPPORTERS WERE
GONNA START SAME PROCESS FROM
OPPOSITION- I BELIEVE OUR LEAD
OPPOSITION THIS MORNING IS- SIR
CHRISTIE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION AS WELL AS
LAURA WALSH WITH SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION- MISS CHRISTY DO YOU
WANT TO. TAKE THE LEAD HERE.
SURE I THINK YOU COULD BRING
HERE STERN MEMBERS I'M SURE
CHRISTY WITH THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION WHICH IS
VOTED UNANIMOUSLY TO OPPOSE THIS
MEASURE. WITHOUT QUESTION
EVERYONE HAS EACH OF THE DEEPER
THE FAMILY MEMBERS WHO SUSTAIN
THIS TERRIBLE LOSS MADE IT
SUFFERED A HEARTBREAKING TRAGEDY
AND IT'S UNDERSTANDABLE THEY
WANT TO CHANNEL. THEIR GRIEF
INTO ACTION. BUT WE MUSTN'T
CONFLATE THAT TERRIBLE TRAGEDY
WITH THE BILL BEFORE YOU WHICH
WOULD ESSENTIALLY ELIMINATE
STATE AND LOCAL AUTHORITY OVER
SHORELINE ARMORING TO PROTECT
PRIVATE DEVELOPMENT. IT'S NOT
NECESSARY IT WILL PREVENT
SIMILAR EVENTS AND IT WILL HAVE
DEVASTATING IMPACTS ON EACH IS
PUBLIC ACCESS IN CALIFORNIA'S
COASTAL ECONOMY. LET'S BE CLEAR
IT'S NOT AS IF THE INGREDIENTS
PLUS GAVE WAY BECAUSE THE
COMMISSION DENIED A RETAINING
WALL THERE. THE COMMISSION IS
NEVER RECEIVED ANY SUCH
APPLICATION AT THAT SITE YOUR
HAS THE COMMISSION EVER DENIED A
PRIVACY WALL IN THE GENERAL
AREA. IN FACT BECAUSE NATIVE
BLASTS ARE ALREADY EXTENSIVELY
ARMOR- ACCIDENT WAS JUST THAT.
ACCIDENT NOT THE RESULT OF ANY.
POLICY OR FAILURE TO ACT. BUT
STILL WILL BE THE MORE SEAWALLS
INCLUDING REPRAP WHICH MEANS
MORE COASTAL EROSION NOT LATCH
THE SCIENCE IS CLEAR HE WON'T
KILL BEACHES BY CUTTING OFF THE
CENTRAL ST SUPPLIED. AS BEACHES
SHRINK WAIT ENERGY ON
NEIGHBORING PROPERTIES
INTENSIFIED HE WILL DEFINITELY
HAVE THEIR PLACE IN SOME
SITUATIONS CALIFORNIA ALREADY
HAS OVER A HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE
MILES UP. THE CAN PROVIDE
IMMEDIATE SHORT TERM PROTECTION
WHILE OTHER SOLUTIONS ARE-
ARRIVED ON BUT IT CALIFORNIA'S
DEADLY TOWARDS SCIENCE BASED
LONG RANGE REGIONAL PLANNING IN
NATURE BASED SOLUTIONS MEANWHILE
SHOULD BE. A LAST RESORT NOT THE
DEFAULT. I T. WOLVES BECAUSE
ELDER FOR ENOUGH ONE CUMULATIVE
COST WILL QUICKLY OVER YOUR-
FOR. I SIX TWENTY SEVEN THE
SCALE IN FAVOR OF C. WALLS
REGARDLESS OF OTHER OPTIONS. THE
COMMISSION AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
WOULD HAVE TO APPROVE THEM BY
RIGHT FOR ANY RESIDENTIAL
DEVELOPMENTS BELT BEFORE MAY OF
LAST YEAR. DISCRETION TO DENY
WOULD BE SEVERELY CONSTRAINED IT
LIMITS MITIGATION TO THE FEET OF
NO MORE THAN TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS A LOCALLY IN
ADEQUATE AMOUNTS THAT WILL NOT
ADDRESS ACTUAL IMPACT. IF
WEALTHY COAST LIKE POLICIES WILL
MAKE IT FASTER EASIER AND
CHEAPER TO BUILD THE WALL. BUT
IT WILL BE AT THE COST OF PUBLIC
BEACHES. THANK YOU MR CHRISTIE
IF YOU DON'T HAVE A PRACTICE TO
MONEY THAT BE GREAT THANK YOU WE
ASK YOU THE- PORTABILITY
COMMITTEE TODAY RESPECTFULLY
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SO MUCH
APPRECIATE THAT MS WALSH. I
THANK YOU IN THE MORNING CARE
TURNING COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF THE
BAR LOS WITH THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION. I'D ALSO LIKE TO
RECOGNIZE THAT ALL OF A THREE
SPEAKING BECAUSE WE CHERISH THE
BEACH WE ALL HAVE REALLY
IMPORTANT MEMORIES THERE. THE
GOOD TO GREAT AND ALSO THE
TERRIBLE AND I THINK WE HAVE A
GREAT DEAL OF RESPECT FOR
EVERYONE. BACK HERE IN THE NEW
YEAR TRYING TO PROTECT WHAT THEY
LOVE FROM VERY REAL CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH THE LEVEL RIDE.
UNFORTUNATELY BILL IS NOT A
SHELTER WE SEEK. THE BILL
ATTEMPTS TO TRADE A STATE BEACH
FOR THE BEACH ITSELF. BY FAST
TRACKING SEA WALLS THAT NARROW
BEACHES. A STATE NATIONAL PARK
IS NOT ONE PAVED OVER WITH
ASPHALT. IT'S ONE EFFECTIVELY
MANAGED AND CURATED. THE SAME IS
TRUE FOR OUR LOCAL BLOOD AND
BEACHES. I UNDERSTAND PUBLIC
ALLOW THE BILL AND HILLARY ROAD
AGAIN AND- OUT A BILLABLE SPACE
. MAKING THE BEACH AND- CAN USE
THAT EVER MORE VULNERABLE TO
EROSION AND WAVERUNNER. BUT IT
DOESN'T MEAN THAT NOTHING CAN
DONE. CALIFORNIA CODE STANDS TO
BENEFIT ENORMOUSLY FROM THE WORK
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE ACHIEVE
JUST IN THE LAST SESSION. MORE
THAN A FEW MEANINGFUL BILL
INCLUDING AT THE ONE EIGHTY
SIXTY SIX AND EIGHTY SEVENTY TWO
ARE IN THE PROCESS OF GOING INTO
A FACT THAT WILL MAKE BLOOD CLAP
MORE PREDICTABLE. AND BRIDGES
ACROSS THE STATE MORE DOCTORS TO
CLIMATE IMPACTS INCLUDING C.
LEVEL RISE AND ROSHEN. THESE
MEASURES ALL HAVE SOMETHING IN
COMMON. THEY BUILD OFF THE C.
LEVEL RISE PRINCIPLES THAT MORE
THAN A DOZEN STATE AGENCIES
SIGNED LAST YEAR WHICH COMMITS
MORE ADAPTIVE AND EQUITABLE
PLANNING ALONG THE COASTLINE.
AND DELEGITIMIZE IMPORTANT VOTER
APPROVED INITIATIVES LIKE THE
COASTAL ACT AND BE GLAD. WHICH
HELP KEEP THE BEAT A VIBRANT.
AND ACCESSIBLE RESORT TO ENJOY.
THIS BILL MOVES THE DIRECTION.
LET COMMITTEE RECEIVED MORE THAN
ELEVEN HUNDRED EMAILS OPPOSING A
SIMILAR VERSION OF THE BILL.
BECAUSE IT CONTRADICTS THE
PROGRESS BEING MADE TO PROTECT
OUR COASTLINE. WITH C. LEVEL
EXPECTED DRIVE HALF OF THAT BY
TWENTY THIRTY. THE STATE REALLY
CANNOT AFFORD TO DRIFT AWAY FROM
ATTRACTED PLANNING. WEEKEND
ARGUED COMMITTEE TO OPPOSE THE
BILL INSTEAD FOCUS ON COASTAL
RESILIENCE STRATEGIES IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO THAT BENEFIT ALL
CALIFORNIANS. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MS WELCH- NO MORE LEAD
WITNESSES- DO WE HAVE ANY
HEARING FORTY TWO OH THREE
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION
NO- MODERATOR WILL TURN TO THE
LINES- AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
ON OUR TELECONFERENCE ARVEST
WISHING TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION- JUST NAME AND
AFFILIATION PLEASE. THANK YOU TO
JOIN THE QUEUE IN OPPOSITION IF
YOU HAVE NOT ALREADY DONE SO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
ON YOUR TELEPHONE. AGAIN THAT'S
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. FOR THE
FIRST ON LINE NUMBER SIXTEEN ONE
SIX PLEASE ELEVEN. GOOD MORNING
TURN MEMBERS NIKITA KARATE WITH
THE NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION TO THE SIX
TWENTY SEVEN THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE LONG. NINE TWENTY. HI THIS
IS LAUREN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
SIERRA CLUB CALIFORNIA CALLING
IN OPPOSITION TO SB SIX TWENTY
SEVEN AND REGISTRY OPPOSITION
OR- CLEAN WATER ACTION
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE CENTER
AGAINST THE BILL AS WELL THANK
YOU THANK YOU MISS COUNTY. NEXT. NINE TEN. HI THIS IS SUSAN
JORDAN THE DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA COASTAL PROTECTION
NETWORK AND I'M CALLING IN
STRONG OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL
AND I HOPE THE COMMITTEE WILL
HOLD IT THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR-
NEXT. A LINE NINETEEN. HELLO MY
NAME IS AMANDA MADISON AND I'M A
VOLUNTEER WITH SURFRIDER YOU CAN
DIEGO AND I STAND WITH THE WAIT
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU NEXT.
BLIND. SEVENTEEN GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MONOCLE FOR ON
BEHALF OF DEFENDERS OF WILDLIFE
CALLING IN OPPOSITION THE BILL.
THANK YOU. NEXT OUR OUR FINAL
LINING WAS. ONE FOURTEEN ONE
FOUR. ON THIS IS SANTIAGO JESUS
OF CALIFORNIANS I'M INTO VOTING
IN OPPOSITION OF SB SIX TWENTY
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT
. AT THIS TIME THERE NO FURTHER
LINES IN Q. OKAY. WHAT I'D LIKE
TO THANK ALL OUR SUPPORT
OPPOSITION WITNESSES- AND BEFORE
BRING THE DISCUSSION BACK TO
MEMBERS I DID WANT TO.
ESPECIALLY THANK DR DAVIS- YOU
KNOW WE SPOKE AT LENGTH LAST
YEAR WHEN- THIS BILL WAS FIRST
BROUGHT TO COMMITTEE. AND- NOT
JUST THIS BILL BUT- THE TRAGEDY
THAT- YOUR FAMILY EXPERIENCED IN
THAT- MANY OTHER CALIFORNIA'S
HAVE WE DON'T ALWAYS REALIZE
THIS HI I WENT THROUGH SOMETHING
SIMILAR WITH A- CLOSE FRIEND
GROWING UP- MUCH FURTHER SOUTH I
MEAN MUCH FURTHER NORTH BUT-
SAME KIND OF. HORRIBLE TRAGEDY
AND I JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT- I
THINK ALL YOUR ADVOCACY IN YOUR
BRAVERY IN SHARING YOUR FAMILY
STORY AND REPEATING THAT. TRAUMA
OVER AND OVER AGAIN HAS YIELDED
INCREDIBLY POWERFUL ACTION I DO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR THAT- YOU
KNOW IT'S NOT JUST THE
LEGISLATION THAT WAS PASSED LAST
YEAR FROM SOME MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH THEIR ATKINS ARE
PETRIE-NORRIS OR YEARS ELLIS
ADVOCATE HERE IN CENTER BATES.
BUT ALSO FEDERAL ACTION IS
PENDING WITH THE ARMY CORPS OF
ENGINEERS LOOKING AT A- A BEACH
NOURISHMENT PROJECT- AND LOOKING
AT A LONG TERM PLAN FOR THAT
ENTIRE REGION- I THINK THAT YOUR
VOICE IS BEING HEARD- WELL
BEYOND YOUR COMMUNITY AND I DO
WANT TO THANK YOU FOR IT. I'M
SORRY THAT- WE'RE STILL LOOKING
AT THE SAME BILL WE HAD A
PRESENTED TO THE COMMITTEE LAST
YEAR BECAUSE I DO THINK THERE'S
WORK TO BE DONE. ON A BEACH
REPLENISHMENT AND IN CERTAIN-
TARGETED CIRCUMSTANCES SHORELINE
PROTECTIVE DEVICES MAY MAKE
SENSE- BUT THE SORT OF. HEAVY
HANDED IN- SINGLE SHOT APPROACH
TO THIS IS A VERY COMPLEX ISSUE.
TO ME POSES SOME SERIOUS
CONCERNS FOR EXACTLY THE REASONS
WE'RE HERE TO SOLVE- WHEN IT
COMES TO- ONE RIVET REVETMENT
FOR SHORELINE PROTECTIVE DEVICE
BEING PUT IN ONE AREA WHAT
HAPPENS TO THE AREA RIGHT NEXT
TO THAT. DEVICE DOES THIS THE
SAND GETS SUCKED AWAY AND-
PULLED SOMEWHERE ELSE WE'VE SEEN
NUMEROUS STUDIES ON THAT THE
PROLIFERATION OF SEA WALLS
WITHOUT INDICATED INADEQUATE.
MANY MEDICATION WITHOUT A
PROCESS FOR COASTAL COMMISSION
FOR STATE AGENCIES THROUGH
SEQUEL TO TAKE A LOOK AT THIS-
SEEMS TO ME A RASH APPROACH TO A
VERY SERIOUS PROBLEM THAT SHOT
NOT BE- RUSH THROUGH THE PROCESS
BUT INSTEAD DELIBERATED ON SO.
YOU KNOW I DO HAVE SERIOUS
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LEAD SOLUTION
I WISH WE ATTACK- DONE REAL WORK
HERE AND I THINK THERE'S A LOT
TO WORK WITH WITHIN THE EXISTING
STATUTORY FRAMEWORK THAT WAS
PASSED LAST YEAR SO- THOSE ARE
MY INITIAL COMMENTS I WON'T BE
SUPPORTING THE MEASURE TODAY-
BUT I DO THINK THERE'S SERIOUS
WORK TO GET DONE. BOTH WITHIN
THE FEDERAL ARMY CORPS FRAMEWORK
IN THE THREE BILLS PASSED LAST
YEAR BUT I WOULD OPEN IT UP TO.
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS MEMBERS- CERTAINLY
DO APPRECIATE ANY FEEDBACK- YES
CHAIRMAN AND THANK YOU CENTER
BATES- THE OBVIOUS I LIVE NEARBY
THIS SITUATION AND YOUR DISTRICT
BUT I'M NOT TOO FAR AWAY MYSELF
AND I REMEMBER. THE NEWS THAT'S
US REMEMBER SEVERAL YEARS AGO-
THAT THIS LEGISLATURE TOOK UP
SOME ISSUES REGARDING BALCONIES
WHEN THERE WAS SOME BALCONY
COLLAPSES IN- IN- BERKELEY AND-
THE LEGISLATURE ACTED QUICKLY-
THERE WAS A LOT OF DEBATE ON.
WHETHER THE ACTUAL LEGISLATION
WAS GONNA MAKE A DIFFERENCE BUT-
THE BOTTOM LINE WAS THE
LEGISLATURE CHOSE TO ACT QUICKLY
AND PASS SOME LEGISLATION. THAT
WOULD MAKE A DIFFERENCE IN THAT
AND I THINK THIS LEGISLATURE
TODAY HAS AN OPTION TO SAME
THING IN THIS SITUATION- AND YOU
KNOW THE COULD THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. MY UNDERSTANDING
THEIR CHARTERS TO PROTECT THE
COAST OF CALIFORNIA. AND THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR THE COASTAL
COMMISSION TO STEP UP AND TAKE
THE LEAD ON THIS. AND ACTUALLY-
RATHER THAN JUST. A COME OUT
AGAINST THIS BILL WITH. MAY BE A
PROPER ARGUMENTS ARE NOT PROPER
ARGUMENTS WILL LEAVE THAT FOR
FURTHER DEBATE AS THE CHAIRMAN.
HI COMMENTED BUT- TO JUST COME
OUT OUT OUT OF OUT OF HAND. TO
OPPOSE THIS- SEEMS AGAINST THE
CHARTER AND THE PURPOSE OF THE
COASTAL COMMISSION IN THE FIRST
PLACE I MEAN THEIR THEIR JOB IS
TO PROTECT THE COAST AND THIS IS
AN OPPORTUNITY TO DO THAT- I
KNOW I JUST WONDER IF. THOSE
COASTAL RIDGELINES WERE
POPULATED BY ENDANGERED SPECIES
HOW MUCH WOULD THE COASTAL
COMMISSION APPROVED TO PROTECT
THAT RATHER THAN- WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING AT HERE TODAY SO WITH
THAT I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE
BILL AND MAKE THE MOTION FOR
APPROVAL AND- HOPE THAT- ENOUGH
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE WILL-
FOLLOW WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
HERE. AND MAKE A DIFFERENCE FOR
CALIFORNIANS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MR VICE CHAIR- COME HERE
CENTER HUESO AND THEN OVER TO
CENTER THERE. OF THE FIRST
INTERNATIONAL. THE THANK YOU
MISTER AND THANK YOU SENATOR
WORKS ON I THINK THE DEBATE- ME
LIES A LITTLE WHAT THE ACTUAL
SITUATION IS AND IF THERE WAS A
BALCONY BILLS STRENGTHENING ONE
BALCONY DIDN'T AUTOMATICALLY WE
CAN THE NEXT BALCONY THAT IS
WHAT IS IN FRONT OF US HERE AND
WHAT IS IN FRONT OF US HERE. IS
THE FACT THAT THIS IS DE FACTO
BY BROUGHT. UP FOR THE
CONSTRUCTION OF FORMER. AND I
HAVE A LENGTHY COASTAL DISTRICT
- THAT RUNS HUNDREDS OF MILES
ALONG THE COAST AND IT'S- IT'S
INTERESTING BECAUSE THERE IS ONE
PLACE WHERE THERE IS A STRONG
SEA WALL. AND AS A RESULT THE
RESIDENTIAL APARTMENT THAT IS
RIGHT NEARBY HAS BEEN
SUBSTANTIALLY UNDERMINED AND
THEY ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
HOW TO PROTECT ALL THE PEOPLE IN
THE PARK MEANT. BECAUSE THE
SEQUEL HAS SHIFTED. OUT OF WHAT
THE PROTECTION REALLY IS AND SO
TO GO TO OUR BY RIGHT SYSTEM.
THAT DOES NOT ANALYZE WHAT THE
IMPACTS ARE THAT ARE SO CLOSE
TOGETHER IS NOT GOING TO BE
HELPFUL IN ADDRESSING THE
PROBLEM AND I THINK THAT. THE HI
PAUL THIS SENATOR FOR RAISING
THE ISSUE. AND ARE ARE AND I'M
REALLY SORRY FOR THE SITUATION-
THAT WAS HIGHLIGHTED AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE TESTIMONY. THE
QUESTION IS DOES THE SOLUTION
MATCH OF WHAT THE PROBLEM IS AND
I THINK IT'S THE CONCEPT THAT IS
A PROBLEM WHICH IS ANY BY RIGHT
THAT DOESN'T SORT OF ANALYZE.
THE DIFFERENT SITUATIONS THAT
ACTUALLY EXIST IN THE MOMENT AND
WE HAVE ONE. IN OUR AREA WHERE.
WHEN THEY BUILT SANTA CRUZ HARD.
IN IN IN WHAT. THEY HAD TO BILL
OUT APARTMENTS ON POSOF TO
PROTECTED COMING IN AND WHAT IT
REALLY DID. IS IT TOOK THIS
BEAUTIFUL EXPANSIVE BEACH ON ONE
SIDE IN THE CITY OF SANTA CRUZ
AND- IT HAS COME BACK IN THE
POLLUTION IS COMING AT THAT
NEIGHBORHOOD MUCH CLOSER. AND
THEN THE BEACH ON THE OTHER SIDE
WHICH WAS MUCH CLOSER HAS NOW
EXPANDED WAY OUT. IN AND THAT IS
THE NET EFFECT THAT HAPPENS.
WITH SEQUELS. IN ORDER TO WORK
WHEN I WAS ON THE CITY COUNCIL
YEARS AGO WE- WE HAVE A ROUGH
TIME BECAUSE IN SANTA CRUZ
THERE'S TWO MILES OF RESIDENTIAL
PEOPLE ACROSS THE STREET FROM
THE NOTION AND WE HAD TO
PRESIDENTIALLY DECLARED
DISASTERS IN THAT PERIOD FOR
ROSHEN. AND IT STARTED TO GO TO
STREETS AND STARTED TO GET AT
WHAT WAS GOING TO BE THE HOMES.
AND WE NO CHOICE BUT TO PUT
RIPRAP IN ON AN EMERGENCY BASIS
TO PROTECT THE PEOPLE THERE. BUT
THE HEAD OF THE LOCAL MARINE
SCIENCES PROGRAM GARY GRIGGS.
HAS BEEN WELL KNOWN AN OCEAN
WORLD FOR FIFTY YEARS. TESTIFIED
TO US. I JUST NEED TO TELL YOU
MOTHER NATURE ALWAYS WINS NO
MATTER WHAT YOU DO MOTHER NATURE
ALWAYS WINS SO YOU CAN THINK
THAT YOU'RE PROTECTING. YOU'RE
REARRANGING THE PROBLEM. IS
POSTPONING THE INEVITABLE AND SO
WHEN YOU HAVE A SITUATION LIKE
THAT. IT DOESN'T CALL FOR
ABSOLUTES IN LEGISLATION IT
CALLS FOR LOOKING AT THE
INDIVIDUAL SITUATIONS AND TRYING
TO PASS PROTECTED IF THERE'S A
HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE MILES OF
PROTECTIONS. THE LONGER
CALIFORNIA COAST ELEVEN HUNDRED
MILES THEN THAT STATES THAT THAT
WAS THE BEST PROTECTION THERE
AND THIS IS ONLY GOING TO BE
SOMETHING THAT IS GOING TO GET
MORE SERIOUS IT IS ONLY IF WE-
IF WE HAVE SEA LEVEL RISE THAT'S
TWO OR THREE. FEET BETWEEN NOW
AND THE TURN OF THE NEXT
CENTURY. IT IS NOT JUST THAT
THAT IS A GRADUAL RISE IT IS THE
EXTREME EVENTS. IS EXTREME
EVENTS THAT DRIVE HOME. ABOUT
RISE AND SO WE ARE GOING TO HAVE
TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE IT'S THE
REASON WE PASSED SB ONE LAST
YEAR BUT I JUST DON'T THINK THE
BY RIGHT SYSTEM FOR COASTAL
ARMORING ITS DISSOLUTION AND I
WILL BE NOT SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY. OKAY THANK YOU SIR FOR
THE CON. IN THE AND THE COMMENTS
AS CENTER HUESO. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND- I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE CENTER LIVE
FOR THOSE COMMENTS AS WELL
BECAUSE I THINK THEY WERE RIGHT
ON POINT AND HE GETS TO MY OWN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE ON THE COAST
COMMISSION OURSELVES APPOINTED
OVER TWELVE YEARS AGO. AND BACK
THEN WE WERE HAVING REGULAR
MEETINGS ON THE ISSUE OF SEA
LEVEL RISE AND HOW THE CLOSE
COMMISSION COULD START TO ENACT
POLICIES TO COMBAT THAT THAT
WELL THAT'S BEEN. MANY YEARS IN
THE PROCESS SAID EVEN PREDATED
MY SERVICE. ON THE COASTAL
COMMISSION AND I UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS IS A PROCESS AS QUICKLY
PEOPLE TO. THE PROBLEM. A LITTLE
KNOWN FACT ABOUT CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE THE HIGHEST POINT
GEOGRAPHICALLY CONTINENTAL
UNITED STATES MOUNT WHITNEY AND
THE LOWEST POINT BACK WATER
BASIN THAT ARE EIGHTY MILES
APART. AND IT SPEAKS TO
CALIFORNIA'S OF THE REASON WHY
THAT WERE THE GOLDEN STATE RIGHT
CHIU THIS IS GEOGRAPHIC MARVEL
BUT IT ALSO SPEAKS TO A LOT OF
SEISMIC ACTIVITY. A LOT OF
CHANGES HAPPEN HAVE HAPPENED IN
OUR STATE'S COASTLINE ALL AROUND
STATE. AND OVER THE YEARS NOT
ONLY IN THE COAST BUT EVEN
INLAND AND ALONG RIVER BODIES
ALONG- GROUND THAT IS NOT. VERY
STABLE WE HAVE BUILT A LOT OF
HOUSING. THAT IS BECAUSE OF
NORMA'S AMOUNT OF DAMAGE AND
ACCIDENTS. AND TODAY WE'RE
MAKING CORRECT TURKEY TAKING
CORRECTIVE ACTION NOT ONLY IN
THE COAST FOR CROSS STATE AND
THIS IS ONE OF THE- THE
CONSEQUENCES OF. NOT BEING
COMPLETELY THOROUGH IN OUR
EVALUATION WHERE IT'S SAFEST TO
BUILD IN THE STATE. SO MIKE MY
CONDOLENCES TO THE FAMILY THAT
ARE OF SOFT SUFFERED- CORBEL
ACCIDENTS AS A RESULT OF THIS.
IT AFFECTS OUR TRANSPORTATION
AFFECTS FAMILIES LIVES. BUT I
RECOMMEND THAT IN THIS FOR I
MEAN THIS THIS BILL I AGREE-
TRIES TO TAKE IN ORDER TO
AGGRESSIVE ACTION TO CORRECT
SOMETHING ONLY IN THE SHORT TERM
MORE THIS THAT WE HAVE TO. BE
MORE THOUGHTFUL AND COME UP WITH
A LONGER TERM SOLUTION THE ONE
THAT'S GOING TO GIVE US THE
BIGGEST BANG FOR THE INVESTMENT.
THAT'LL HELP US SOLVE THESE
PROBLEMS VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
CENTER LOOP LEAD DESCRIBED IN
TERMS OF LOOKING UP. AT A
COMPLETE LOOK AT OUR OCEAN AND
LOOK AT PROJECT BY PROJECT I
RECOMMEND. THAT THROUGH YOUR
TRANSACTION TO OUR ACTION HERE
THAT WE WORK WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT AND CITY LEADERS TO
PROPOSE I HEARD THERE WERE SOME
SOLUTIONS THAT- WERE PROPOSED BY
THE ARMY CORPS OF ENGINEERS IF
THEY REALLY HAVE SOME SOLUTIONS
THEY SHOULD BE. PROPOSED THEY
SHOULD BE PUT IN FRONT OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT IN FRONT OF THE
COSTA COMMISSION AND WE SHOULD
START WORKING ON INDIVIDUAL
PROJECTS THAT SOLVE THIS PROBLEM
IN A WAY THAT DON'T EXACERBATED
I BELIEVE THIS LAW WILL
EXACERBATE THE PROBLEM
STATEWIDE. THEY MIGHT BE A GOOD
LAW IN THE CASE FOR INSULATORS
MAYBE THIS ONE PROJECT BUT IT
WILL DEFINITELY CAUSE A REVERSAL
OF SOME THE PROGRESS HAS BEEN
MADE LIKEWISE AND STUDYING HOW
TO ADDRESS ADDRESS THIS- SAT AT
A STATE WIDE. LEVEL BUT
INDIVIDUALLY NOTHING PREVENTS
THE CITY OF ENCINITAS OR ANY
PROPERTY OWNER OR ANY ENTITY IN
PARTICULAR FOR PROPOSING THE
PROJECT INCLUDING THROUGH YOUR
ADVOCACY WORKING WITH YOUR LOCAL
LEADERS AND SOME OF YOUR
CONSTITUENTS TO PROPOSE SOME OF
THESE- IMPROVEMENTS TAKE SOME OF
THOSE SUB UP PROPOSALS FOR SOME
OF THOSE IDEAS AT THE ARMY CORPS
OF ENGINEERS HAVE. HAVE COME UP
WITH AND PUT THEM INTO A
PRACTICAL SOLUTION. AND APPLY
DIRECTLY THROUGH THE- REGULAR
PROCESS TO ENSURE THAT THESE
IMPROVEMENTS ARE MADE TO.
PEOPLE'S PROPERTY AND LIVES ARE
PROTECTED IN OUR COASTLINE. IS
ALSO PROTECTED IN IN ITS
ENTIRETY SO- ARE ENCOURAGED YOU
TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON THAT I
HAVE I PLEDGE YEARS ADVOCACY FOR
YOUR DISTRICT AND THE PEOPLE
THAT YOU REPRESENT. AND HOPE
THAT YOU CAN- MAYBE COME AT THIS
PROBLEM FROM A MORE DIRECTION
LUCIEN WORKING WITH THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU SENATOR.
THANK YOU CENTER- ANY OTHER
COMMENTS QUESTIONS- I HAVEN'T
HEARD ANY QUESTIONS THE AUTHOR-
BUT I WOULD ALLOW YOU THERE'S
BEEN SOME COMMENTS MADE IN YOUR
CLOTHES PERHAPS YOU WANT TO.
RESPOND TO SOME OF THOSE- OR
TAKE WHATEVER TIME YOU WANTED TO
CLOSE AT IDC CENTER ALLEN OUT
THERE AS WELL BUT- I'LL JUST
I'LL BRING IT BACK TO THE AUTHOR
IF THAT'S OKAY. THANK YOU
CHAIRMANSTERN AND THANK YOU
MEMBERS FOR. THE DISCUSSION. I'D
LIKE TO SHARE WITH YOU JUST VERY
QUICKLY THE R. E. I WILL CALL IT
THE EVOLUTION OF US SENATOR
BATES SO GETTING. INTO THIS
PARTICULAR ISSUE. WINNOW THE
TRAGEDY OCCURRED AND HENCE THE
NEED IS AND CERTAINLY THERE
WERE. MANY THREATS BEFORE THAT
THAT I. THE WEARER OF BEING A
ALL COASTAL RESIDENTS. BUT I
LOOKED AT CHAPTER THREE ARTICLE
FOUR OF THE CALIFORNIA COASTAL
ACT. WHICH SPECIFICALLY IF
THERE'S A BY RIGHT IS CONTAINED
IN THAT SECTION ON THREE OH TWO
THREE FIVE I BELIEVE IT IS.
WHERE IT SAYS REVETMENTS
BREAKWATERS GROWING HARBOR
CHANNEL C. WEALTH CLICK
RETAINING WALL SHALL. SHALL BE
PERMITTED WHEN REQUIRED TO SERVE
COASTAL DEPENDENT USES. OR TO
PROTECT EXISTING STRUCTURES ARE
PUBLIC. BEACHES AND DANGER OF
EROSION. SO I LOOK AT THAT I
THOUGHT I WAS WITH. WORK AND WE
WERE LOOKING OUT LAW. AND
INTERPRETATION THE COUNTY LEVEL
AND I WAS A TRAINER AT THAT TIME
FOR MY UNIT- WE LEARNED THAT THE
TERM SHALL IN STATE LAW AND
SHALL IN IS NOT DISCRETIONARY.
SO WHEN I SAW SHALL I THOUGHT
WOW HERE'S AN APT IN THE COAL
ACT AND PROVISION OF SUCH SHALL
SELENE BY RIGHT WAS NOT CREATED
BY SB SIX TWENTY SEVEN HE WAS
ALREADY IN THE COASTAL OUT
SUBSEQUENT TO AMENDMENTS. AND
CERTAINLY CHANGES OVER TIME WITH
THE WITH THE TERM EXISTING
STRUCTURE. AND THAT HAS BEEN
DEFINED AS ANYTHING BEFORE I
THINK OF DEAL TO NINETEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN HOWEVER PASSED
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN. THE
COASTAL COMMISSION DID APPROVE
OF DEVELOPMENT OF STRUCTURES IN
PUBLIC INFRASTRUCTURE SUBSEQUENT
TO THAT TIME. SO THERE'S STILL A
LITTLE DEBATE ABOUT EXISTING I
WOULD ALSO POINT OUT THAT
EXISTING STRUCTURE OF BILLS THAT
ARE NATURALLY CREATED STRUCTURES
WHICH HAPPEN TO BE THE BLUFF.
THOSE ARE NATURAL GEOLOGICAL
STRUCTURES ALONG THE COAST OF
CALIFORNIA IN MANY CALLS FOR A
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND CERTAINLY IN THE WORLD. SO
TO ME WHEN I LOOKED AT THE OFTEN
I'M TRYING TO THINK OF WHAT CAN
WE DO TO US. TO ACCELERATE-
SOLUTIONS THAT WE ARE SEEING
THEIR AMOUNTING OVER ON C. LEVEL
RISE AND AN ADDITIONAL
CONSTRUCTION BASICALLY OF PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE HARBORS CHANNEL
FOR BOTH CONTRIBUTE. DAMMING
RIVERS CONTRIBUTE TO THE LOSS OF
SOUND NOT JUST SEE WHAT. WE KNOW
THAT FROM THE EVIDENCE
SCIENTIFIC EVIDENCE. SO IT SEEMS
LOGICAL THAT WE WOULD BRING THIS
FORWARD SO I APPRECIATE THE
DISCUSSION I THINK IT OPENS UP A
BROADER DISCUSSION OF WHAT CAN
HAPPEN IN THE NEAR TERM AND I
CERTAINLY APPRECIATE WHAT.
SENATOR HUESO SAID ABOUT TRYING
TO GET SOMETHING THAT IS HIM ON
THE MERCHANT. CAN SOLVE THAT
RIGHT NOW IS REALLY REALLY
IMPORTANT FOR THE LIFE AND
CERTAINLY FOR BEACH ACCESS. FOR
THE PUBLIC IN THE LONGER TERM
ABSOLUTELY WE'VE GOT TO FIND A
LONGER TERM SOLUTION THAT
DOESN'T HAVE TO GO THROUGH THIS
VERY TEDIOUS- PERMIT PROCESS
LOCAL FULL COMMISSION HAS TO
DEAL WITH AND I KNOW IT'S NOT
EASY FOR THEM. TO HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE FOR THE EACH AND
EVERY APPLICANT I CERTAINLY
APPRECIATE THAT THERE'S A LOT
HERE I DO BELIEVE THAT CAN
CONTINUE DISCUSSION I CERTAINLY
WILL TAKE THAT ON. BUT YOU YOU
KNOW THAT I FEEL VERY PASSIONATE
ABOUT THIS AND I DO THINK IN THE
COASTAL ACT IN THIS PARTICULAR
AREA. NEEDS A DEEPER DIVE INTO
WHAT IT ACTUALLY MEANT AND I
KNOW THEY'RE BEING COURT CASES
TAKING LOOK AT BACK. STILL IT
DOES NOT DISCUSSION GOING ON BUT
I DO THINK WE HAVE TO LOOK AT
STRUCTURES AS SOMETHING THAT
INCLUDES BLUFF. NOT JUST PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND NOT JUST
PRIVATE PROPERTY STRUCTURES.
SOMETHING HAS TO BE DONE TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN PROTECT OUR
COLLECTIVE POLICY TO PROVIDE US
YOU ALL ARE VERY FAMILIAR WITH
THE CHANCE THAT THEY HAVE OVER
THEIR SLOPES. SO THERE IS A
RELATION THAT GOES DOWN AND
HELPS REPLENISH BUT IT DOESN'T
FALL DOWN ON CARS AND PEOPLE AND
BEACH GOERS. SO WE NEED TO TAKE
A LOOK AND CERTAINLY WITH SB
ONE. THANK GOODNESS WE GOT THAT
PASS AND THERE'S GOING TO BE I
THINK WHAT IS THAT A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY.
THERE'S MONEY THERE TO DO
SOMETHING SO LET US NOT JUST
STOP. HERE BECAUSE THIS BILL I
DON'T THINK IT OUT THIS WITH.
VERY TO ALL UP THE DISCUSSION
INTO A LOOK WHAT WHAT DID ARMS
STATE. VOTERS MEAN WHEN THEY
PASSED LOCAL FLAT THAN THIS
WITHIN A- IT IS LIFTING
STRUCTURE AND- SEVENTY THREE
WHEN PAST. DID THEY THINK ABOUT.
ALL OF THIS OR WOULD THAT JUST
WHAT WAS THERE WHEN THE BILL WAS
PASSED AND I DON'T THINK THAT'S
WHAT IT WAS BECAUSE I HAPPEN TO
VOTED FOR IT. SO I THOUGHT IT
WAS EVERYTHING INCLUDING THE
PROTECTION THAT WE NEED FOR A
COASTAL BLUFFS THE REAL ON PCH
THERE THE DISCUSSION WE'VE GOTTA
MOVE PCA FOR WE'RE GONNA MOVE
IT. I LIVE ABOUT HALF A MILE
FROM THE- IS A COME UP TO MY-
WITH EMINENT DOMAIN EVERYTHING
SOUTH EAST OF PACIFIC COAST
HIGHWAY INTO WE CAN MOVE IT OUT
OF THE SEA RISE PROJECTION NO SO
THERE ARE SOLUTIONS OUT THERE
IT'S JUST GOING TO TAKE ALL OF
US WORKING TOGETHER AND I
CERTAINLY WILL CONTINUE MY
INVOLVEMENT. OF AGAIN THANK YOU
CHAIRMAN STERN WE'D WE'VE BEEN
HAVING THIS DISCUSSION NOW IS IT
TWO YEARS. BACK TO I'LL KEEP
AFTER YOU AND YOU'LL KEEP AFTER
MEDIAN WELL I KNOW THAT
SOMEWHERE. IN ALL OF IT THERE
THERE IS AN ANSWER AND THANK YOU
SENATOR LAYER I YOU WERE AT THE
HEADWATERS OF THE US WHEN YOU
WERE HARD AGENCY OF DIRECTOR.
AND I KNOW THAT YOU HAD TO DEAL
WITH THAT THEN AND YOU HAVE A
COASTAL AREA BUT AGAIN IT IS
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY VERY
IMPORTANT ON CERTAINLY FOR THE
SAFETY OF THE PUBLIC OPINION.
MANY MANY ASPECTS WITH THANK YOU
AGAIN. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CLOTHES CENTER BATES AND AGAIN
FOR YOUR ZEALOUS AND- UNYIELDING
ADVOCACY ON THIS ISSUE- ALL
DISCUSSION HAVING SEIZED- AND
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION FROM OUR
VICE CHAIR- SO MISTER CONSULTING
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY STERN NO STERN NODE
JONES JONES HI ALAN. ALLEN NO
EGGMAN. EGGMAN NOT BUILDING
GROWTH I GROWTH HIGH HERTZBERG
NO HERTZBERG NO WAY SO. HUESO
KNOWS THE MOAN MOAN LAYERED
LAYERED NO AS TO FOCUS OKAY- THE
MEASURE FAILED- AND- LOOKS BUT
WE WILL CONTINUE THIS AND OUR
OUR OUR HERE THANK YOU CENTER
BATES FOR ALL YOUR WORK TO
APPRECIATE IT MEMBERS THAT THAT
WAS IT FOR OUR AGENDA HERE
TODAY- SO WE'LL BE SEEING YOU
ALL VERY SOON BUT IN THE
MEANTIME JUST BE SAFE OUT THERE
AND TAKE CARE. OF THIS MEETING
IS ADJOURNED.